here we go here we go here we go here  they come she looks absolutely gorgeous  doesn't she as always baby wrapped up  warm congratulations congratulations  from all of us I'm sure they'll come  down the steps a little closer waving to  the prize some have you've been here for  a fortnight or even more taking easy in  those heels she's done it again how  impressive is that I would come over and  talk to us  they didn't waving to the crowds just to  the right of them also to the staff who  are leaning out of the windows here at  st. Mary's Hospital on the walkway as  well we're hoping that they'll walk  maybe a little tiny bit closer and  perhaps give us a few words certainly  posing for the photographers and the  media from right around the world  recognizing one or two people in the  crowd the press back of course traveling  right around the world with the royal  couple so they're not going to be taking  any questions yet as far as the names  are concerned Arthur is the front runner